how are you doing in the pandemic i mean
like
are you are you over it or
are you you know i mean under it or are
you under it
or inside it i don't know i mean it's
hard to explain
i i take it seriously i respect it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
that that that's one of the things
that's driving me crazy right now so
yeah
all these [ __ ] anti-massacres yeah
all these conspiracy theorists
right just do what you're [ __ ] told
put the mask on
listen to the experts people that have
dedicated their entire lives to science
yeah okay there isn't a [ __ ] agenda
here yeah the eject well there is
it's trying to rid the world of this
virus this nasty disease yeah it's
killing people
yeah you know i have this friend of mine
in the uk where i come from and on
facebook he's had it all the [ __ ]
time
okay going on it's okay i'm like and i
never respond
but i just couldn't do it last night i'm
sitting down okay
i wrote this big long response yeah yeah
and he came back with
his initial response was her really i
thought better of you to be honest i'm
like oh really so somebody has a
different
opinion than you right we'd have to
listen to your [ __ ] uh
you left school at 16.
all you've done since then indeed he
left school at 16. yeah yeah they
haven't held down
a a a shitty dead-end job your entire
life yeah yeah yeah
right and you're gonna sit there and
disagree
with scientists that have studied their
entire lives to understand these things
he's like oh yeah
but the government keep changing
guidelines i said well yeah of course
well that in itself tells you that they
are learning
and changing the uh as they're learning
about the [ __ ] virus right if it was
an agenda they would just say right this
is the way it's gonna be
these are the control mechanisms we're
putting in place yeah and like it all
[ __ ] lump it they wouldn't keep
changing things yeah yeah they're
adapting as it goes because this is a
new thing
correct and we are the same we're in the
same boat you know even if you were
weren't i don't wouldn't care but um
yeah no for sure you know whatever
yeah i'm not gonna fall out with people
over it but it does get a little
exhausting
yeah yeah yeah i was that i went to a
comedy night
friday at somebody's house yeah and
one of the girls there looks at me she's
a friend of mine she goes
right because i had a shield and a mask
on yeah right
it's like what the [ __ ] you know you're
older you know
you're kind of you're in that
demographic yes you know frail
he's geriatric weak yeah you know i mean
you know a good gust of wind would knock
you off
you need the shields as you were saying
though sorry i interrupted your story
anyhoo
how rude how [ __ ] rude you limey
bastard
lifey
a little bit of a sluggish but yeah yeah
that's a good word you dress
real well yeah yeah you're a cool again
so um and she goes
you know you know the people that die
from corona
uh coronavirus is people that um that
took the flu vaccine
last year and then gets coveted so the
combination of the two
kills you it's actually quite the
opposite and she goes take the mask off
oh really yeah and i go no yeah like i'm
not gonna listen to you
yeah who the [ __ ] are you yeah right so
everyone has these different opinions
and whatnot but um well everyone's just
at each other's throats
so it's not even a matter of like what
you believe i think that people are just
generally frustrated
and they want to go after something and
someone so it's like
in those situations like you just gotta
accept to
disagree and then move on yeah i did
yeah people are very
frustrated and certainly people that
have lost their jobs and lost their bank
accounts
it's difficult it's a difficult and
that's the difference to what i'm
dealing with
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah and
my thoughts are with them truly
but i pulled my phone out here because i
posted this the other day and it's so
true it says quick reminder
if the roles were reversed and it was
younger people who were more likely to
die
our grandparents and parents would do
absolutely everything they could to
protect us
but on the flip side we're like oh it's
just the old [ __ ] right right i've
lived that long
that's an interesting thing i'm glad you
said that yeah imagine if you and i love
you first and i love you you will
[ __ ] do i love you too
whatever you could to protect your
children and your grandchildren yeah you
wouldn't say oh [ __ ]
he's 60 years old that's still young
yeah you know i mean you're almost right
there
she's still got life left to live bob
oh [ __ ] this guy
anyway you have a demon baby to me yeah
we have a demon baby
so i i want to say that i have also this
podcast
has been very fun for me
is it done no we have to do our
unhelpful advice oh my god we've just
driven all this way we just got here